hi everyone today I'm at the University
of Sydney some familiar faces some new
we've got Peter Liam and Rainer and
today we're going to take a look at a
couple of experiments these are both
versions of the double slit experiment
and they're going to be at two vastly
different price points so we're just
going to compare them in that you know
see if it's worth it to put in the big
box for this experiment now the double
slit experiment really looks at the
wave-like nature of might because we are
setting up an interference pattern by
passing light through to narrow and
close together slits so let's see what
we can make first of all on the cheek
we've got some blades and we've got a
little laser pointer so here on the
camera we have a few failed attempts at
the double slit so trying to get to
really close together was not actually
as easy as it might sound
these are nowhere near close enough to
set up the interference pattern yeah
little do you know if you use a roller I
think it becomes easier yeah we want to
move it just far enough that the other
medium is not gonna tear itself apart
they have to be very close together
otherwise it just acts like a so what a
single slit diffraction pattern looks
like is if we just pass the laser a
single slit would give something that
was some high intensity in the middle
and goes out to sort of lower it is your
fainter towards the edges for a single
slit we also see a pattern of light and
dark regions here is a comparison pick
from Wikipedia
since the slit is wider than the
wavelength of light we treat the wave at
the slit as a large number of point
sources and we get interference because
of differences in path links from each
contributing ray Peter will briefly
explain wave interference basically a
big peak coming together in a wave it's
a larger peak right or you can get a
peak trough right when they're pulled
out of phase and they counts allowed to
form nothing zero and you you get that
in acoustic waves all right so when you
have a guitar and the frequency is very
close right and it starts beating so it
starts creating these peaks and troughs
and they start combining and kind of
interesting ways but you can also get
that with light so while you're there
we're trying to achieve something called
the double slit so how is that going to
be different what why would they
recently different on the board you can
imagine save waves coming up okay wait
France and when they keep this they're
gonna come out instead of coming through
what they come out this way
yeah yeah yeah I do have a video about
this and leading on to using single
particles to do this but we're just
using light at the moment and so like
what Peter was saying before like peaks
and troughs can either cancel each other
out or reinforce each other to get
bright spots and dark spots that are now
on the wall that are a result of you
know two different diffraction patterns
it was actually a really fundamental
experiment in history of science for
that matter yeah sure
and it's really cool that we can do it
so relatively simply well let's try and
continue with that somehow experiment
okay where's the foil that's cool
awesome they're pretty close together
hopefully they close enough
well dummy getting good patent and so
we're just taking a cheap laser just
firing that onto the board so that's
still a single slit cameras so yeah I
can see like a lot of bands Oh slightly
different from the singles Wow yeah we
see that that's cool
the camera is definitely hard look it
with my finger that's good but yeah that
is a pretty good interference pattern
for a piece of foil and a laser pointer
it looks great it looks very cool it's
very nice I'm not sure how expensive is
the laser pointer I suppose you'd have
to buy a whole all of this right sir
okay oh no maybe you can just get it
with Al foil from so what what is this
very expensive looking olive oil this is
scientific grade elephant that's
aluminum tape that you can buy from like
most electronic shops like Jake R or I
was gonna say do we think we can try it
I'd say probably yeah it's a problem
okay so how much how much would be the
cheapest one these usually cost about
$20 for a roll let's go scalpel
I reckon you could pick one up for about
five bucks like you want a good shop one
with a good laser pointer from even yeah
say five dollars five
$10.10 the better the bowl together cuz
that's a separate video okay very cool I
was pretty happy with that she I don't
know if we can get much better than that
double-slit interference pen because
that was pretty nice spot we will try
with Aleks pencil setup expensive
Southwick apartment we have here we have
a much more expensive laser who knows
the price made of this laser yeah that
is a 20 mil award helium neon laser
which will set you back something close
to $2,000 for the laser and the power
supply thank you it's a very nicely yes
so we have this which is a series of
precisely made double slits early more
accurate than now it's but they will you
pay for really just two components that
we're working with yeah yes so this is
about $2,000 this is about blinding
double slits will be about $200 cool so
very good oh we didn't we didn't count
you could substitute this for an
excellent man yeah could be the most
expensive item at all yeah especially
exactly anyway but that's a common
factor between bottoms that's okay yeah
this wouldn't be an eye safe laser I
mean it's not going to apply to you
instantaneously but it will blind you
definitely not and reflections can be an
issue as well as you can see because
we've got a mondo pretty much perfectly
the reflection is coming straight back
to the laser which is good for us
thankfully the restriction on laser
pointers is only for handheld ones so we
can get nice strong ones as long as they
have key in a power supply see how these
cameras pick it up with two slits I'm
actually just going to turn off the
lights just so we can get a beautiful
cinematic
[Music]
[Music]
oh that looks amazing yeah but like this
is obviously much more world you can
really see the interference pattern and
the bands
[Music]
what's with all of these the ones above
and below vengeance quite an important
experiment in physics because we're
really looking at right here the way of
like properties of light which is
something that you know when they were
discovered sort of blew people's minds
and so we can try to appreciate this
holy balls my mind right now yeah we can
appreciate what we're actually looking
at I believe that this was chosen not
only because it sets up a wonderful
double slit expensive and you wanted to
really taste the top level of
experimentation yes is this the most
expensive laser we could have used that
we own definitely yes it has a very
narrow peak so you get a very nice
pattern diode lasers can be just as
expensive but there's still their peak
as as narrow so you'll get a little bit
more
the laser pointers are diodes I think I
think the thing that's interesting to me
about all this is that like I know we're
kind of doing this like cheap expensive
experiment as a bit of a bit of a joke
in a bit of a gimmick but what I really
love is that you can see fundamental
properties of our universe right like
how like what light is and how light
works for like with a really cheap laser
and a scalpel and some aluminium foil
right and like it's nowhere near as
pretty as this right but you can still
draw the same conclusions right and kind
of the idea that the people who are
experimenting with this for the first
time it didn't have lasers back then
do they have no 60s
yeah they would just collimated light
and then focused it but yeah i think i
think that's like to me that's one of
like the wonderful things about physics
it's like you just get to play around
like like what are your experimenting on
is you know everyday stuff right and the
fact that it can do it but really really
cheap equipment to find something so
fundamental about the light that just
kind of blows my mind how this would
actually go with our expensive laser
here well let's do some science and find
out and you don't want to reuse the
aluminum to reflect the laser beam into
someone's eye you may yet put it in
white side
oh you know I'm enough true it's hard to
see interference I'm thinking that might
be single
could be single oh that's pretty for a
second there there was something else
that's a beautiful single I think the
slit
well the slits are just too far apart
the beam is actually mmm what we might
need to do is actually it doesn't
singles the bringing this back
we run encourage the beam slightly
and so we're just using the central
maxima
from a good English look at him to try
and make a double stripper so the beam
diameter of this laser is too small to
work with these all right
that's why we hadn't that's why we have
bad lasers because these beams are so
for our purposes a pointer was actually
better yes yeah just as we're
considering what the final price points
will be we're thinking we'll probably
need to include some of these rails and
other things that actually enable us to
use this laser so liam is looking up a
quote for a rail and we'll add this as a
mis kite Amman the quote look I'm saying
it really would come it's priceless
because you know it is all they were
very nice these ones move and stuff so
yeah yeah read it and it would come with
a set so the total for the cheap
experiment works out to be five plus
five plus ten cents so it works out to
be ten dollars and ten cents okay
the eternal for the fancy one
is 2,000 plus 200 plus 300
coming in at a significantly higher
price point but did we really gain that
much more value from this yeah I think
this is the discussion with critics
getting here you know I think yeah I
think we saw the same thing that we
needed to see you know yeah imagine if
you were discovering the effect for the
first time I think the cheap one would
have definitely led us onto the fancy
one yeah I think why would we even need
such a fancy one maybe demonstrating to
a lot of people and we want something to
be reliable maybe this is more reliable
but but the fact that he can do this
with you know maybe a bunch of
schoolkids and doesn't certainly do at
home so I'm also we're not recommending
you try this on home son have a shop but
also to be careful with your lights and
lasers and scalpels yeah all right thank
you for watching us play with some
double-slit experiments today hope you
maybe learn something I've got something
spur a Shinto try yourself thanks to you
guys for being in my video I'll put some
links down in the description to some of
their channels and other things that
they work on I'll see you next time
thank you I would like to thank
brilliant org for sponsoring this video
brilliant have a course on science
essentials including waves and
interference if you would like to learn
about these topics in an engaging way
then I would encourage you to go to
brilliant org slash tibbie's and sign up
for free the first 200 people to follow
that link will also get 20% off an
annual premium subscription if you want
something more advanced than the science
essentials you can also explore some of
the most challenging ideas across math
and science
total through the chief experiment works
out to be $10.10 that's reasonable
Australian so like a little bit cheaper
us so like $8.00 something 700 something
and the total for the fancy experiment
school kids so the total or the cheap
experiment is 10 plus 5 it wasn't 10 we
took those five Jesus no no no it's fine
okay today I would also like to thank my
supporters on patreon I recently
launched a patreon and if you would like
to have your name appear here on the end
screen you can follow a link in the
description I would like to thank every
single viewer for your support and
helping me reach 100,000 subscribers I'm
really grateful for that and I'm really
excited to keep making videos for you